lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
crear una hoja de cálculo sencilla para
ayudarnos a comprender por qué si r es
mayor que se nos podría llevar a que
cada vez más del ingreso nacional vaya a
las manos de los dueños del capital en
lugar de a la mano de obra
digamos que eres 3% más adelante
podremos cambiar esta suposición es lo
que suponemos es el rendimiento de
capital y suponemos estará fijo a una
tasa constante y digamos que el
crecimiento económico es de 2% supone
más un escenario en donde r es mayor que
se en esta columna ponemos los años 12
hasta el año 15
ahora pensemos en el capital total en
nuestra economía también nos interesa el
ingreso nacional podemos verlo como la
salida de la economía y ahora veremos
cómo se reparte el ingreso nacional
entre el capital y la mano de obra
ingreso al capital aquí y el ingreso a
la mano de obra acá
aquí tenemos el capital como un
porcentaje del total hagamos algunas
suposiciones digamos que mi capital
agregado aquí voy a poner un número
aleatorio es 4000 podrían ser 4.000
millones de dólares o solo cuatro mil
dólares pero se diagnóstica sobre el
dinero en este caso digamos que nuestro
ingreso nacional es de 1000 y ya hemos
visto en gráficas que al menos para eeuu
el capital nacional como porcentaje del
ingreso nacional ha sido del 400 al 500
por ciento ha oscilado en ese rango de 4
ó 5 veces el ingreso nacional por lo que
esta no es una razón desproporcionada
cuál será el ingreso para los dueños del
capital bueno dijimos que el rendimiento
del capital es del 3% por lo que esto va
a ser igual a este 3% y voy a oprimir
efe 4 para que se pongan estos signos de
moneda para asegurarnos que quede fija
esta celda cuando arrastremos hacia
abajo esto más adelante será esto por la
cantidad del capital que tenemos en la
economía por lo que no os quedará 120
noten que los signos de moneda de la
celda b1 es para fijar esta referencia
pero no puse los signos de moneda en vez
5 porque quiero que esta referencia
cambie cuando arrastre esto hacia abajo
así que cuando arrastre esto aquí quiero
que no cambie la referencia a b1 pero
que se multiplique por lo que sea el
capital de ese renglón y veremos cómo se
hace esto en un momento
cuál es el ingreso para la mano de obra
pues el resto esto - esto y el capital
como porcentaje del ingreso total será
el ingreso para el capital de 5 dividido
entre el ingreso nacional de 5 lo que
nos da un 12% también vamos a suponer
que el ingreso para el capital siempre
se reinvierte al capital cada año es
decir no se consume de otra manera en el
año 2 el capital con el que iniciamos
será el capital del año anterior más el
nuevo ingreso al capital pues éste se
reinvierte como capital ahora el ingreso
nacional será el ingreso nacional del
año anterior x 1 más este número que es
nuestro crecimiento económico y presionó
de nuevo f4 para fijar esta referencia
noten que esto creció un 2%
y estas tres celdas de acá las podemos
arrastrar hacia abajo espero que ahora
pueden apreciar lo que hice aquí cuando
puse los signos de moneda porque ahora
lo que arrastre esto seguirá
refiriéndose a b1 multiplicada por veces
que es esto si no es algo muy útil que
las hojas de cálculo vamos a darle
formato de porcentaje a toda esta
columna para que se vea más limpio y
ahora si podemos continuar copiaremos
esto hacia abajo y permítanme quitar
algunos de los lugares decimales de aquí
bueno que es lo que tenemos vemos que
cuando eres una tasa fija de rendimiento
de capital mayor que el crecimiento
vemos que el ingreso que va al capital
como porcentaje del total de el ingreso
aumenta
esto podría usarse como una
representación de desigualdad porque
como mencionamos con anterioridad el
capital tiende a concentrarse en el 1%
superior o el 10% o 25% superior pero
como les comenté esto es solo una
representación otra cosa a tomar en
cuenta es que la desigualdad es un
subproducto natural de una economía de
mercado capitalista aun cuando cada vez
más del ingreso va para los dueños del
capital el ingreso a la mano de obra
también ha aumentado esto por sí solo no
necesariamente es algo bueno por ejemplo
si la población aumentará más rápido que
esto entonces el ingreso a la mano de
obra dividida entre la población o el
ingreso per cápita de la mano de obra
que es una representación de lo que un
individuo trabajador gana este aumento
no sería algo bueno porque la población
crece más rápido que esto
pero suponiendo que la población es
estable y no crece tan rápido como esto
incluso aunque vemos desigualdad aquí
porque cada vez más del ingreso va al
capital a estas personas puede irles
mejor en esa situación para probar la
sensibilidad de este modelo que creamos
podemos cambiar algunas suposiciones por
ejemplo si el rendimiento del capital es
mayor un 5%
vemos que la disparidad es mucho más
significativa si esto lo cambiamos al
10% pues vemos una situación que podría
volverse desagradable de hecho esta es
una situación muy extrema ya que ahora
el ingreso a la mano de obra se
decremento
así que importa mucho en donde se
encuentren estos números ahora que si el
crecimiento económico se pone robusto no
sé un 9% tendremos un muy buen escenario
para todos los involucrados tenemos una
representación en donde aumenta el
ingreso al capital y aumenta la
desigualdad pero
quizá la economía crece lo suficiente
como para que todos se beneficien los
invito a que construyan un modelo como
este y jueguen con los números para que
tengan un mejor entendimiento de que si
suponemos que raíces son constantes y
hacemos otras suposiciones sobre el
capital inicial y el ingreso nacional
veremos como éstas se van repartiendo
conforme avanzamos en el futuro